[Applause]
thank you thank you very very much it
was a pleasure to see you always nice to
have you i bow to you i treat you with
more respect than brokaw uh
no no i love the man he's been good to
us uh
i want to say first of all it's got to
be
you've had this amazing success in the
last year with american pie yeah that
film went through the roof oh big time
that's a showbiz expression it means it
did well yeah it went
went through the bake shop window that's
right yeah i've never heard that
expression that you just made that up
uh but it was extraordinarily successful
how are you best pie screwing movie i've
ever seen see
now go back to the big shop window thing
did uh now but how how have you dealt
with that success has it you know
what for you i i mean it's been great i
mean you know the success of that movie
has been absolutely wonderful the sad
thing is it's it's you know it's it's a
movie you know they're doing a sequel
coming up soon but they could they can
you know no matter how many sequels they
do and no matter how old my children
become it's a movie i will never be able
to see with my children it's just one of
those movies you don't see with your
children yeah it's got a little move
you know we got a little uh you know a
little uh there's a kind of a
masturbation thing there's a you know
humping a pie thing there's uh there's a
you know a bit of oral sex there's
somebody drinking a beer with something
i'm saying you know what
you can't sit down beside your children
and kind of elbow them going hey what do
you think of that one huh
hey sweetheart look at this what do you
think
it's your old
man in
there you see what he did to that pie
huh you know my son was my son was
supposed to come to the premiere i don't
know if i told this but my son was
supposed to come to the premiere
last year when it opened he was 16 at
the time
and uh and he had talked to a friend of
his before the uh the opening who had
seen a sneak preview of it and uh and
and the friend said boy it's really
funny that you know it's it's a very
funny movie and my son said yeah i'm
going to be seeing it tomorrow night
with my dad and the guy goes oh big
mistake
big mistake don't see it with your
father and then my son had to come up
and say well dad you know maybe maybe i
won't go to the opening and uh you know
i'll see it with my friends and i'm
really glad that he made that decision
because you know not having seen the
film right
i was glad that you know my son and
daughter weren't there
well best this is a different movie this
best in show it's not it's it's a
different film you're doing now yeah uh
you have a very different look in this
movie
uh you look you don't look much like you
do right now no well i had a i had a i
wanted a uh a look that would uh knock
about 40 points off my iq right
so i had a little dental thing
done okay
um
and uh
and there's there's a look right there
let's get into this we're not talking
we're not talking barnum and bailey here
but it's just enough to kind of uh
accentuate the facial features
and what it does do is
it kind of uh it kind of dumbs you down
about uh 40 50 60 percent
and the thing is that uh while i was on
the set and had these teeth in it was
very uh very difficult to have people
take you seriously when you're talking
about just about anything because they
uh right for some reason they would
chuckle they would giggle they would
laugh i couldn't quite understand why
and then i realized hey i still have my
teeth in
those are nice i like they come out and
go down yes they do
yeah
no you do look like a now uh thank
you
thank you very much you had to train for
this film this film is about dog should
i finish the interview with the teeth
then yeah i think so let's keep the keys
you uh you had to train because you play
a uh you play a uh
well what we have this film is about um
this film is about the dogs i'm losing
my concentration i have to admit you
should take those out
this film is about uh dogs in the world
of dog shows right and uh this is uh
again like our last film waiting for
goffman a uh completely kind of
hilarious
uh completely kind of improvised uh a
movie which is kind of fun but it's
about the world of dog shows so we did
have to as a cast we play the owners and
the handlers
that enter our dogs into these shows so
we did have to uh
we did have to uh train and um
and what do they have to know what
special skills do you need to know if
you if you work as a dog show uh you
know trainer or judge well what you what
you have to do is be able to show your
present your dog so it shows well we had
to you know a larger dog you have to
walk your dog into the arena you have to
know how fast
to walk so that the in other words if
you're walking a large dog you would
walk slower because the dog has longer
legs if you're walking a smaller dog you
have to walk quicker so that the dog
walks quicker and and his gait is is
showing itself off more attractive yes
the more difficult thing for me was uh
what they call stacking the dog because
uh
uh which is
you know the dog i had was a smaller dog
was like a a terrier
um
yeah they were very you were kind enough
to uh
uh
so this is like the work yeah this is
the size of the dog that that we had to
to to to kind of work with right and
stacking the dog means that uh when the
judge is examining uh your dog in the
event itself
you have to lift the dog from the floor
so that the dog the judge doesn't get
down on his hands and knees right and
have to examine the dog on the floor so
you you have to lift the dog onto a
table so the judge can examine him more
easily but you have to lift the dog up
and place him so that he's already set
in his best showing
position so the tough thing was you know
uh i don't know if i can demonstrate
here but the uh the left hand
goes under the neck okay on the dog like
like so
and uh the right hand goes around
you split your fingers i don't know what
you call them on television is that a
correct fingers is fine yeah oh finger
so uh so the right hand here goes right
around this and this is the uh
uh
i'm not making testicles
oh testicles that's right i'm sorry
so you you you what you do is you you
you lift the dog so he stays straight
right and you put him
down and he is in the perfect uh
position and it's it's not an easy thing
and i thought this is the perfect
position
oh i guess if i'm the judge if you're
the judge okay right this sets the dog
straight so his head is his head is
right because your hand's under here
nice and his back legs are spread like
so because your your fingers doing that
that's
well arousing me and i want it to stop
you know you know we're just we're
pretty much out of time is there
anything so that's pretty much it yeah
well i wanted to do we have time because
i wanted to it's a tricky kind of thing
and i didn't know whether you want me to
give it a try i i would love for you to
just uh okay you know let's do that kind
of a tricky thing now i'm going to use
this just to keep things going here i'm
going to
i'm going to use this to in case you'll
use that one what do you want me to use
well i want you to use another dog that
we're bringing in here
come around
can you you want to come around hi
sweetie hi hi sweetie look at this
little dog
i do okay well the dog is up like this
first of all
yeah hi honey look hmm all right
i'm not touching this dog
i don't know this dog we're gonna take a
break but uh best of luck with the film
that was it was a sweet ending when you
kissed a dog and i'll kiss you eugene
levy everybody we'll take a break